this is how Central Bank digital  currencies are going to steal your  freedom so during the height of the  pandemic in Canada those who went to  protest bodily autonomy because they  didn't want to take some kind of magic  juice which turns out to be actually  quite dangerous their bank accounts were  frozen and so they had to stop  protesting and so with this Central Bank  digital currency because it is  programmable you just program the money  so that they can't buy a plane ticket to  go and protest and then also many people  were sending Bitcoin to help the  truckers but with the Central Bank  digital currency you can't even send  money to help these people and so with  the Central Bank digital currency it  will absolutely steal your freedom